this video is brought to you by keeps
avast ye mateys marooned sea dog Jared
here - hmm
talk about a 20-19 film so unpredictable
that the phrase jaw-dropping feels like
an absurd understatement the lighthouse
whenever a movie leaves me feeling that
weird cocktail of impressed aw and
confusion I have to wonder is this film
too smart or is it just pretending to be
let's investigate in this wisecrack
edition on the lighthouse deep or dumb
and of course spoilers ahead but before
we get into it I want to give a shout
out to keeps a lot of you know how much
I like my hair it's part of my identity
so I'm scared out of my mind about
losing it and from what I've learned
prevention is the key if you've noticed
your hair thinning and want to keep
yourself from going bald you've probably
already invested in prevention
techniques but staying out of the Sun or
throwing away all your hats won't solve
the problem because genetics are the
main cause of male pattern baldness
keeps is a prevention tool you can use
to save your hair keeps offers
fda-approved treatments to combat the
symptoms of hair loss with keeps you
meet with a doctor online or to your
prescription or over-the-counter
medication and get everything delivered
right to your door with keep some men
even experienced hair regrowth if you're
noticing hair loss do something about it
and try keeps today click the link in
the description or go to keeps calm
slash wisecrack and you can save 50% off
your first order and now back to the
show all right guys let's do a quick
recap lighthouse spotlights no pun
intended the relationship between season
lighthouse keeper old played by Willem
Dafoe and his reluctant mentee young
played by that vampire guy who's
arguably the best young actor of the
moment anyway old is gassy and Gaslight
II potentially screwing with young for
his own amusement putting him through
punishing physical labor and constantly
trying to get him wasted bad luck to
leave and toast unfinished back all this
while also refusing to let young look at
his precious Lantern the day before
they're supposed to finally leave
everything goes buckwild young kills the
out of a seagull causing a gnarly storm
to brew and then is like man do I need a
drink the men bond open up about
pass and even sing fun sailor songs when
the ferry fails to pick them up things
to generate fast young who we've learned
killed his former boss and assumed his
identity I just stood there as long just
just stood watched him get swallowed by
them logs loses all the and beats up old
eventually killing him but not before
pausing to hallucinate him as his dead
boss a mermaid and a squid creature then
young finally gets to see the light
which is a beautiful serene experience
kidding it just about kills him and we
end on an onion liam lying naked on a
rock while birds peck at his innards
which we have thoughtfully concealed
with Nic Cage gifts okay so what in the
name of Poseidon just went down the way
we see it there are countless possible
ways to glean meaning from this film so
we're going to focus on three aesthetics
psychosexual dynamics and mythology
let's start with aesthetics
according to the film cinematographer
Jaron Blaschke Edgar said that
atmosphere comes first and then the rest
comes out of that and boy this films got
atmosphere for days it feels out of a
different non specific time with an
old-fashioned boxy 1.19 to one aspect
ratio that visually smushes the two men
together and makes us increasingly
claustrophobic they also mimic the look
of orthochromatic film which dates back
to the early days of photography and was
particularly used for portraits
fittingly the first frontal view of
young and old is presented almost as if
they're posing for an old-fashioned
portrait as they gaze at the camera
unnaturally still orthochromatic film
filters out red light giving the sky a
washed out look and people's faces a
darker more textured complexion it's
evocative and surreal and makes the
actors look weathered as hell because
they were using old lenses in an old
style of film everything about the
production process had to be super
meticulous the orthochromatic look
requires a ton of light in the film set
was so bright - that apparently some
film crew members wore sunglasses even
during nighttime scenes which is
honestly just called style there's some
intimation throughout that light is
dangerous the interior shots grow
steadily brighter as old learns more
about young shady past and of course the
lighthouses extreme brightness seems to
basically kill young at the end but it's
not totally clear now this film probably
has the coolest aesthetics of 2019 . but
try as we might we couldn't unearth any
overarching meaning behind them so for
this one we're going to say atmospheric
as hell but not quite deep though
definitely let us know if we're missing
something let's move on to part two
sexuality aka your high school gym
teachers second expertise don't have sex
because you will get pregnant and die
from phallic lighthouses to vaginal
keyholes sex is front and center which
is fitting for a movie that features
dudes jerking their lighthouses about
every five men
it's most obvious in the tensions
between young and old who like your
boomer parents vacillate between yelling
and each other and embarrassingly slow
dancing the queerest subtext are pretty
clear and Eggers along with actors
Robert Pattinson and Willem Dafoe told
The Huffington Post that this was
intentional the whole thing is about
power dynamics so it is about willing
pushing pushing pushing pushing pushing
and there's pent up anger and pent-up
erotic energy and pent up smells where
is that breaking point
indeed the struggle for power is central
to the plot old claims absolute control
telling young to throw the rulebook away
because he's the king of the castle he
alternates between telling young to do
the hardest possible chores and yelling
at him for having supposedly done them
wrong even dangles him from a rope just
to be a jerk these dynamics come to
fruition in a bizarre mirror image when
young takes old for a walk like he's a
dog in an image that feels straight out
of a kink handbook here young is
expressing the dehumanization he felt
when old regularly called him a dog
suave dog swap and reclaiming his power
taken on its own old behavior is just
dickish put in the context of physical
and emotional relationships with young
though it becomes pretty clearly erotic
as if to bring the point home Eggers
evokes the work of sasha snyder a late
19th century queer painter who had to
flee Germany because of his sexuality
and one of the film's most striking
moments Eggers recreates this schneider
painting called hypnosis which depicts
one man's face shining light onto the
face of a younger man as if revealing
some frightening and seductive truth is
Eggers perhaps suggesting that
interacting with old reveals some
frightening but seductive truth about
young maybe a new gradation of his
sexuality now we're not saying that
they're gay and neither is Eggers it's
hardly that simple regardless of which
way they typically swing they enter into
a tacitly erotic relationship out of
loneliness or genuine sexual attraction
there each fulfilling a need of the
other old gets to feel in control
despite living in a world dictated by
the uncontrollable forces of the sea and
as for young Robert Pattinson explains
of his character in a lot of ways he
sort of wants a daddy and boy does he
get one the pure erotic fascination is
given plenty of time to brew on screen
there's lots of secretly watching one
another from a distance and old even
calls young and innocent picture there's
also moments of reprieve
softer images of their relationship like
when they sit peacefully by the fire as
old engages in your traditionally
domestic hobby of knitting however they
still manage to make even peaceful
feminize tasks impetus for more
hyper-masculine aggression not
incidentally their most tumultuous fight
erupts over whether or not young likes
olds cooking ice a night you're fond of
me lobster rather than expressing his
pain and vulnerability something he
might see as overly feminine old
immediately turns to his most wildly
violent impulses literally calling on
Triton to jogi engorging your organs dei
turn blue and bloated with pills and
brine and can stream no more yeah that
old sick ass sea dog monologue brings us
to another point
the film's treatment of the nebulous
line between sex and death take this
climactic moment when young finally sees
the light
what is he experiencing just pain or a
weird pleasure in pain that strange
duality has fascinated many thinkers
including George batai whose book
erotism death and sensuality outlines
the odd relationship between these two
aspects of human experience
according to Bataille we are from the
very beginning individuals existing in a
state of discontinuity from those around
us that is a state of isolation and
loneliness death lurks us out of a
tenacious obsession with the lasting
this of our discontinuous being that is
it literally destroys our sense of a
singular separate self in doing so it
actually affirms our continuity of being
or as literary scholar Modesto too puts
it in depth we go from separate beings
to a common ontological ground of being
because we both desire that continuity
and fear our inevitable death we search
for continuity elsewhere specifically in
eroticism as but I put it the whole
business of eroticism is to destroy the
self-contained character of the
participators as they are in their
normal lives
ie to destroy our discontinuity by
uniting intimately with another in this
way eroticism is a psychological quest
not alien to death because both were
about recovering our lost continuity
overcoming our profound sense of
separation this idea feels very present
in the lighthouse most apparently when
young finally sees the alluring lantern
which has already been thoroughly
sexualized the moment feels in line with
'''but eyes definition of the sacred in
that it seems to cause young both divine
ecstasy and extreme horror a phenomenon
we also see in Jung's earlier
masturbatory adventure in the shed which
ends with him on his knees in pain now
according to bataille the experience of
the erotic that is the tearing down of
your usual self containment is rupture
as' eroticism is often violent the link
between violence and erotics manifests
in the many brawls between young and old
when they can be just as easily about to
make love as they are about to kill one
another but the dichotomy is most
glaringly obvious in the moment right
after the two almost kiss when instead
of locking lips they lock fists right
here we have a textbook example of two
dudes not being able to distinguish
between love and violence fittingly for
this moment but I opine that extreme
seductiveness is at the boundary of
horror which we certainly see in
frightened reaction to olds embrace in
the lighthouse there's a porous
relationship between sex and death love
and violence some literal and some
symbolic more subtly there's the ongoing
motif of a post-coital cigarette first
seen when young lights up after jerking
it to his favorite half woman half fish
of course the post bang sig is coyly
being repurposed for both sexual and
violent encounters young describes
wanting a cigarette after watching the
letting and or causing his boss to die
all I could think was I I could use me a
smoke and he also lights up after
killing old
what's more the original script even has
him doing the same thing after killing
the seagull underscoring Eggers
intentions
similarly old pulls up his suspenders
after his rendezvous with a lamp a
moment the script describes as as if
getting dressed
after a night with a woman echoing this
moment young pulls up his suspenders
after beating old to a pulp as of
getting dressed after sex sex death
what's the difference all in all the
unique take on sexuality and the
interesting treatment of the line
between sex and death love and violence
feels pretty deep to us let's conclude
by looking at mythology the lighthouse
evokes parallels to numerous myths
fables and folklore drawn from a myriad
of seafaring cultures for example the
idea that seagulls contain the souls of
dead sailors is a real maritime myth
which may have brought about the
historical superstition that killing a
sea bird is bad luck this effect was
most famously described in the 1798 poem
The Rime of the Ancient Mariner which
shows a sailor doom his ship by killing
an albatross as punishment he is forced
to wear the dead bird around his neck
like an especially unattractive scarf
young is regularly tormented by a
hostile one-eyed seagull upon learning
that the bird is team Jacob he beats it
to death in a violent rage this appears
to seal his fate as the wind suddenly
change direction and a storm ensues
but there's more one-eyed imagery to
haunt your dreams when Jung inquires
about the previous junior wiki old
replies that he went mad and died a
second
I'd went mad he did later on Jung seems
to hallucinate the severed head of a man
with one eye the resemblance between the
one-eyed former keeper and the one-eyed
seagull is undeniable so what does it
mean was the previous keeper attempting
to warn young about the malevolence of
the lighthouse possibly then there's the
mermaid who appears both as a figurine
and an actual part lady part fish with
and this is according to Edgar's a
vagina modeled after that of a shark's
equal parts beautiful and terrifying the
mermaid has symbolized erotic danger
everywhere from medieval churches to
Greek mythology where sirens lured many
a horny sailor to his doom frequently in
such tales mermaids pull their Sailor
lovers underwater leading to some pretty
awkward one-night stands such a moment
happens during Jung's masturbatory
fantasy and or nervous breakdown in this
way the mermaid helps solidify this
affirmation link between sex and death
then there's the other assorted oceanic
imagery which tends to revolve around
old this is most notable during the
men's deadly fight in which old seems to
spontaneously sprout squid tentacles
before also fading into a barnacle
covered version of himself that sorry
honestly just recalls this guy oh and he
also fades into the mermaid what's going
on here is old simply emblematic of all
see lore representing the way some men
subsume their lives and identities to
the ocean waves and thus gets swallowed
up in all its mysteries maybe we
honestly don't know and then of course
there's the allusion to the Greek myth
of Prometheus the Titan who was punished
by Zeus for stealing the secret of fire
and miss towing it unto humanity in this
myth fire symbolizes humanity's
curiosity for knowledge and triumph over
nature the titular lighthouse exists in
the film as a font of forbidden
knowledge and the object of Jung's
obsession and you know it's also
literally a flame now the gods punished
Prometheus for being a bad boy by
chaining him to Iraq for all eternity to
have his liver eaten by an eagle every
single day only to regenerate at night
in the final scene the film we see
Jung's liver being pecked upon by a
one-eyed Seagal outlaw Prometheus the
gods also punish manatee by giving it
its first woman Pandora described in
Greek poetry as a beautiful evil through
Pandora and her dang box all the evils
in the world are released the theme of
femininity and beauty as beguiling and
dangerous is telegraphed throughout via
the mermaid
as well as the assorted attribution of
feminine traits and duties to both old
and young is young being punished for
stealing the fire of the lighthouse is
it the result of his fear of femininity
and his latent desires to be honest
we're not totally sure and were not
totally sure if it's deep okay so this
has honestly been one of the harder
films we've ever analyzed and we think
we know why
Edgar's himself has said that he wanted
to make the movie inconclusive he wanted
to raise more questions than answers he
wanted us to spend hours on reddit
trying to understand the significance of
the lobster trap this is a pretty cool
approach that not many directors are
brave enough to take lest they be
labeled pretentious we truly applaud it
the only downside is that such an
approach can result in the film not
articulating any clear meaning the
lighthouse is many things at once a love
story a hate story a story of madness
and obsession but despite all these
gradations no interpretation fully makes
a clear statement the movie lacks a
thesis and it does so intentionally as a
result we're a little dumbfounded it's
clearly not superficial but can you be
deep if you're not fully articulating a
message we're genuinely not sure so
we're gonna split the difference and say
quite possibly deep and quite certainly
not dumb but what do you think
wisecracking has Robert Eggers broken
deeper dumb or is there another
interpretation we like a one-eyed
seagull simply cannot see let us know
what you think in the comments thanks to
all our dope patrons for supporting the
channel and our podcasts hit that
subscribe button like it's an angry old
sailor who's making you shovel call and
as always thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]